shoes
hello my name is Elis strablov and I'm a
professor at The Graduate School of
Business Stanford University
specializing in venture capital and
private equity
one of the classes I co-teach is Angel
and Venture Capital financing for
entrepreneurs and investors today are
five takeaways from this class
[Music]
success in startup investing is not just
due to luck as many believe but also
skills sweat perseverance this is my
spend over 100 hours on due diligence of
just one startup making a dozen
reference calls to check on the idea
Founders product Market
they debate startups opportunities and
risks with their partners
the skills of how to conduct due
diligence are critical as is the
appreciation that it is hot and often
unglamorous work
as an investors conduct such extensive
due diligence Founders need to get fully
prepared for it
as I summarize it to my students to be
Founders ask yourself all the questions
if you were an investor
then your aim is to have a great answers
to all these questions depth is
absolutely critical also identify your
weak spots investors avoid shallow
Founders who don't know the ins and outs
of their startup as my former student
who now is successful investor told me
if I come away from meeting the founder
without learning anything new it's a bad
sign
Founders should remember success is all
about execution most investors would
rather invest in a plus teams pursuing B
plus ideas rather than b plus teams
pursuing a plus ideas
[Music]
the third takeaway is that you need to
know the ins and outs of contracts in
the research space
these contracts determine how any
proceeds from startup's outcome are
determined that is who is paid what when
how and how the decisions and startups
life are made
we actually spent most of our course
discussing all these contracts in great
detail
Financial Security and startups are very
unusual if you compare them to
traditional debt and Equity securities
they need to take into account that many
startups fail
that startups raise many rounds of
funding from many investors
and their investors need patience
the takeaway is to understand this
contract and contractual terms really
really well
[Music]
importance of corporate governance that
is how decisions are made in startups
for example lead early stage VCS
typically become board members get
shareholder voting rights often they get
special Vita rights to prevent the start
of taking certain actions without their
approval
these rights help protect investors how
often minority shareholders in the
startup and are afraid they could be
expropriated by others such as the
founders Founders may also be concerned
that VCS May kick them out once they
control the startups board
understanding corporate governance its
implications and negotiations around it
is really a critical skill in the world
of startups
foreign
result is that valuation serves many
purposes apart from just finding out
what the security or company fair value
is especially for early stage startups
varying startups is often about how to
divide the future pie
the world of startups even uses its own
jargon instead of valuation used
elsewhere the post-money evaluation of
the pre-money evaluation is used for
startups in class we discuss at length
these and other valuation terms remember
one thing that the post money evaluation
is not the same as the fare or the
market value in fact my research shows
that post money evaluation is typically
higher than the fair value a result with
far-reaching practical implications
so if you take all these five takeaways
to hot and utilize them either as a
founder or as an investor then you are
much more likely to succeed in the world
of Angel bench capital investment in the
world of startups good luck
foreign
[Music]
if anybody would have told me even even
20 years ago that I would ever teach
French capital I would love but now that
I teach venture capital and pride Equity
I think that is really the most amazing
thing to do to meet Founders investors
who are really passionate about what
they do and trying to help them
both at Stanford and outside is truly
amazing
[Music]